hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at converting
our 2d renderer into a batch renderer
basically something that would be able
to batch together many quads into as as
little drop-off as possible and in this
case into one drop oh check out that
video if you haven't already that was
kind of the beginning of that and today
we're going to be continuing on with
that and adding textures to that batch
renderer so let's talk a little bit
about textures how do textures work in a
bash renderer well I actually have a
video on that topic check it out if you
haven't already I made an entire series
on bash rendering that covers all the
stuff in detail and we kind of
implemented just OpenGL my game engines
nothing like that so it's super simple
make sure that you check out that series
so that you're familiar with how a batch
render works and in fact I also have a
video of me writing a batch renderer in
an hour so check that out as well
because that's like a complete batch
renderer in an hour
you can look at all that stuff there and
see how everything works and that way we
don't have to waste time here talking
about stuff like that but anyway
textures what are the kind of challenges
when it comes to textures in a batch
render well there are two considerations
that I think are important first of all
how many textures are you going to allow
because we can have basically as many
causes we want because we're basically
just limited by how big our vertex
buffer or index buffer can be now we've
elected here to have 10,000 max quads
per draw pool that's a fine number to
start with you can easily increase that
to a hundred thousand maybe even to a
million depending on what your GPU is
going to actually define your maximum
vertex buffer size as and all of that
kind of stuff there however 10,000 is
fine for now but you have to think about
what other limiting factors go into how
many quads you can actually bash
together in a draw call and textures is
a huge limitation because you cannot
have 10,000 different textures bound for
rendering in a single draw it just
cannot be done what you need to do
instead is look at what your maximum
limit is on your GPU so for how many
textures you can have bound at once so
this is something called like a texture
slot limit essentially how many how many
textures can you have bound at once into
as many slots as your GPU driver
actually
with and then after querying the driver
you can kind of see how many textures
you have but now this this other thing
called by analysts textures and there's
a few other kind of driver extensions
that kind of let you get around this
limit but we're not really going to talk
about that today because support on that
can be flaky and we're trying to make
this Feli like standard by the book so
at least for now we're not gonna add any
kind of experimental stuff so at this
point in time basically what I'm saying
is we have a maximum texture slot count
meaning that our GPU can only bind X
amount of textures at once now for those
of you unfamiliar with how this binding
works because I think we've pretty much
been only but only binding one texture
like at any one time so far your GPU has
many different texture slots for binding
you don't just have to bind one texture
once and then rebind another texture
when you do that it actually goes into
slot zero that's like the first texture
slot now typically a desktop GPU should
have at least like 32 texture slots
which means that you have index 0
through 31 you can bind your texture
anywhere there and that index that you
bind that texture into that is actually
what the sampler gets set to in the
shader so in open G in OpenGL in jello
cell we have something called a sampler
2d which is like a 2d texture sampler we
set that to an integer using a shader
uniform uniform one eye so an integer
uniform and that what the integer that
we set there is the texture slot that
we're going to be sampling from and the
actual texture bound through that slot
we set that before we draw so in other
words I can just basically say that this
sampler called u underscore texture just
you want to score texture we can set
that to an integer value of 5 and then
before I draw I can bind any texture I
want to slot number 5 or as OpenGL calls
a texture unit 5 and then obviously if I
sample from that you underscore texture
uniform sampler in the shader I will get
the data I will be sampling the texture
that I bound to slot 5 that's how
textures weapon OpenGL it is different
than other api's as we will see in the
future hopefully in this series of we
expand with like volcano DirectX and
stuff like that but that's how it does
how it works in OpenGL so what we need
to do is we need to find out what the
maximum texture slot is now we're not
going to do that today because I'm
probably gonna be going to take a look
at like GP capabilities in like a
different video because there's a whole
list of things we want to be able to
query our GPU that were running hazel on
to see you know what level of
anti-aliasing can we support what about
anisotropic filtering what about like
you know our maximum texture size what
about like the maximum textures loss
there's all these different things that
we actually want to and there's like
hundreds honestly enough onus them all
there's so many things we want to
actually query the driver for that
usually technically what you would do is
you'd probably add like some kind of
renderer capabilities class and then
that basically on startup just queries
the driver and sees what we're dealing
with so that's something we'll add in
the future and when we have that we'll
be able to set our maximum share a
maximum number of texture slots to what
that needs to be now for now we're going
to assume that the maximum texture slot
count is 32 fairly safe you know on
mobile devices it might be like eight or
something quite low I'm fairly sure we
should have at least 32 - was lots to
deal with especially if you have a
dedicated GPU so we should be ok with 32
texture slots that means index 0 through
31 then what we need to do is when a
texture is submitted so when we want to
draw a quad with a given texture what we
need to do is actually add that texture
into some kind of collection some kind
of data structure that basically says
that ok this texture right is in the
system because it's very common for us
to want to render many quads with the
same texture so this could be if we're
using a texture atlas like a sprite
sheet or something like that and then
that way you know it wouldn't really
matter like we don't we're have to bind
like a hundred different textures for a
hundred different tiles right we can
just kind of have one sprite sheet bound
and then sample from that same texture
many times maybe we have like like I
don't know some kind of terrain or
something that obviously will use the
same texture over and over again there's
many many different use cases for this
the point is we need to see if that
texture has already been submitted in
this drawer because then we don't have
to use up
the texture slot for a unique texture
since that texture already exists now if
we try and render 32 unique textures and
in fact it'll be more like 31 because
remember we have that white texture
which means no texture at all it means a
color of vertex color is actually being
used instead of a texture in that
scenario because of that because that
takes up texture slot zero we'll say we
have one three thirty one so 31
different texture slots to actually bind
to we need to if it's a unique texture
occupy another texture slot for that
draw call and then push that texture
into that slot and then we can bind it
right before we actually call gel draw
elements to render that's the idea now
if we submit more than 31 textures so in
other words let's just say that I've
tried to render something with 40 unique
textures that's not gonna work in one
draw call it's just not so what's gonna
happen is as soon as we hit that limit
we need to basically end this current
batch flush everything so that we draw
that on the screen and then start a new
batch and by starting a new batch we
take out text just lots back to 1 and we
start the whole process again so we can
keep submitting new unique textures if
required now in that scenario if we do
actually draw other stuff with textures
that used to be used we're gonna have to
resubmit them but it should be ok and to
be honest drawing with 32 different
texture drawing and I don't know in my
experience a 2d renderer if you're
making a 2-d game or something like that
drawing with more than 32 textures is
not something I see too often in one
draw koala mean like obviously if you're
dealing with post processing and all
these kind of other things and yeah that
will like use many textures but that's a
different drawer call so it doesn't it
doesn't count if you're drawing your
base geometry with 132 textures for a
2-d game that's not even that common in
my experience because again in a 2-d
game like when I think of 2d game like
starchy Valley like that kind of stuff I
don't know why I keep using stock
valleys an example just keeps popping
into my head and I used it once so I
keep reusing it but if we use something
like that as an example it's it's not
like you know 512 by 512 textures like
they're quite small and because of that
you just add them into a texture Atlas
you could easily fit everything into 32
into 30
textures right no problem so because of
that it's not even a scenario that comes
up that often and if it does you know
you definitely wouldn't be using like
more than say a hundred textures which
means that fits into four drawer calls
and then you know it doesn't really like
performance-wise doesn't really matter
so that's the plan I just wanted to be
really thorough with my explanation so
that you guys know what is actually
happening here and now let's dive into
the code and take a look at how we can
make all of this texture stuff happen so
scrolling through our texture 2d class
if we just launch hazel right now and
see what where we're at we have these
two kind of quads that we drew these are
both bashed together into a single draw
call now let's actually draw like the
channel logo or the maybe the hazel logo
will be more appropriate on this texture
and see if we can actually do that so
the first thing we need to do is extend
our API to actually take in a texture
now at the moment we still have some
kind of API here because if you remember
from the previous time we just kind of
reused an existing draw quad function
which was this one to add it into the
batch and that was kind of it and I
think that like this for example goes
into because this is a texture this goes
into the texture function which doesn't
actually use anything here like what I
mean by that is it doesn't use any of
our batching whatsoever so we obviously
need to fix that up draw rotated court
again with like all that stuff we're not
going to cover that today but what we
should be able to do is basically take
these two functions here and convert
them into into our batch rendering
situation so let's take a look at that
so the first thing we need to do is look
at what we did for here because this is
basically going to remain the same let's
grab that we'll copy that I'll kind of
keep this code here just the same way
like I did here just because you know we
need we want it for reference I mean in
fact what I like to do is instead of
commenting stuff like that I usually
just write an if 0 that way and you can
you know if you want to be more
descriptive you could call this if you
know old path or something like that you
can use that because obviously that's
not going to be defined as the same as
if 0 so we can keep that here and then
we basically have a little bit set up so
let's talk about the very first thing
that we kind of come up with here which
is the color right what does our color
need to be well what I like to do is
just
right a little constant expression here
can be just be constantly doesn't matter
but we'll set a default color of one you
can have this like statically defined
somewhere or whatever but I like to have
it inside the scope of the function
because it makes sense like it's just
you know it's just here it's right here
you don't have to look through a huge
code base to try and find what the color
actually is I mean obviously you could
just you know go to that definition but
this is still easier the next thing we
need to do is actually take a look at
this texture and decide whether or not
it is as I mentioned earlier if it's
already been submitted in this draw
because if it has we don't in turbine it
again and to do that we obviously need
some kind of data structure so what I
like to do is basically write some kind
of well data data structure that will
hold all of the texture slots that we've
got bound now I like to use just a
simple stack based array for this we're
going to hold you and 32 T's these are
meant to be an identifier for the actual
texture now this is where we run into a
little bit of an issue how do we
uniquely identify a texture we don't
really have anything for that yet now
you could go the kind of simple approach
and just be like okay well the OpenGL
renderer ID right that will be my
identifier and that's probably what
we're going to do for now but the way
that we would fix this properly and the
way that we that you would expect this
to work in a game engine is by basically
saying that well a texture is an asset
and every single asset has an ID like an
asset handle essentially and that
uniquely identifies that asset that's
super important because you know and we
will definitely talk about assets in the
future I want to confuse you guys too
much right now but in the future we will
have kind of our assets broken down into
the actual asset handle which just
points to the actual asset and then the
actual asset would be like a texture or
a 3d model or you know a sound file or
something like that that's super
important because it means that if we
have an asset that's in use and we want
to swap it to a different asset
completely so let's just say that we
have this asset pointing to this to this
texture but we've modified the texture
on disk and we want to just like you
know
slap in the new text wrong maybe we want
to change it to a completely different
texture right if that happens and we're
just dealing with assets we're just
dealing with textures and not asset
handles then obviously that all system
breaks because this texture will be a
particular texture but then we need to
learn a different texture in which means
that what are we going to have to go
through our whole engine replace every
single reference to that texture to the
new one that's completely unreasonable
so what we do instead is we have an
asset handle which is kind of like a
container of an asset so it works kind
of similarly Tiger I guess two smart
pointers now we have like a shared
pointer it could be pointing to this
thing but you could reassign it to
something else all right that shared
point object you could still hold a
reference to that and everything would
be fine it's just next time you reach
for it it will be pointing to a
different location and that's kind of
the concept of assets in that sense we
would have some kind of goods like a
globally unique identifier for a
particular asset and that is what we
would have here in the in the actual
like STD array because we don't have
that for now we're just gonna use around
your IDs but I wanted to be super clear
that this is not ideal and when we
actually introduce assets and asset
handles and all that stuff this will be
we'll have to rewrite this to make it
proper again and as I mentioned we're
gonna have a Maps texture slots
situation so we'll write u + 32 T max
texture slots and we're gonna just set
that as 32 so this will be a to do
render caps I'll say so renderer
capabilities so this will be something
we'll get from there so max texture
slots and then we'll call this our I
guess we'll just call this our texture
slots that will be nice and easy
and unfortunately here we actually have
to give this static which I didn't
really want to do I forgot about that a
little rule but it's okay we'll deal
with that so we have texture slots and
then the other thing that I want to have
is our actual texture slot index so
we'll probably start this at 1 the
reason being that texture slot 0 is
going to be our white texture right and
so because of that we're never going to
write a texture that we want to render
into slot 0 start with one and we'll
actually have to reset this true back to
one at the beginning of our scene ok so
what we'll do here is we'll just say s
data texture slot index equals
that way we'll start overriding all
about texture slots again at the
beginning of a neutral call okay so with
texture slots being set to vs right
these are going to be these are
completely empty
right we should initialize this so what
we'll do is over here maybe at the end
of all this we'll just say s data
texture slice and I could just pretty
much just set them all to zero using a
memset probably not the best thing to do
like why could you try to fall it might
make more sense but at the moment I'm
kind of just feeling like doing this
so we'll do size of s texture slots dot
size and obviously I meant you went to
the HVT will do something like that
okay cool so now we're initializing all
about texture slots to zero and in fact
I'm the way to this code turned out
right now is I'm not really digging it
so I actually I'm gonna write it as a
for loop so this is going to go through
all of our texture slots here and just
set them to zero sometimes like even
though that might be one line of code
and it might be nice and simple I think
this is I just think this looks better
to be honest and I think this is going
to make sense to more people so it's
important to write code sometimes that
is like this so let's just say set or
extra slots to zero okay this is
something we'll do in the NIT function
as initialization not definitely not
something that we need to do every frame
or every draw nothing like that okay
cool
now you'll notice here that we have this
kind of in the text shader we have this
kind of you texture uniform and this is
set to zero that's our sampler now we're
gonna have to have an array of these and
we'll learn about that in a minute but
before then if we go back to our draw
quad that takes in a texture the idea
here is we actually want to find a
texture index for this particular
texture so in other words what we
basically want to do is and this was
I've kind of explained this I think in
more detail in my writing a bash round
write in an hour but essentially we need
to try and find a texture index for this
particular texture and see if it's
actually inside our texture slots if
it's not a twitch
it will still be zero since we didn't
find it we need to actually put it into
our texture slot array so to do that we
need to basically set texture index true
and we'll make this a float to our
texture slot index right which is
whatever that happens to be up to that's
the next available texture slot so in
the feed in a scenario of us not drawing
a single texture before we hit this
function it would have been set to one
right and it would have been reset to
one in the begin scene okay because zero
as I mentioned is that white texture so
this is now one texture slot one is now
going to be occupied by this new texture
that we are trying to draw so now what
we'll do is write s data texture slots
at this new index which I can well I'll
use this because this is an hour float
remember so we'll say sth slot index and
we'll set that equal to texture ID now
texture ID which I'll write out here is
going to be the ID of this right so we
literally need to say texture get
renderer ID okay so once we've got and
we don't have that function apparently
so we'll set that up in a minute but
that is that that is the basic idea and
then this texture index which is now a
texture slot that we happen to be using
this is now the texture slot that we
will bind this texture to when it comes
time to actually render it that's the
whole idea so what we need to do here is
go to and to be honest I may actually
change this over to be like a ref of a
texture 2d and then we'll actually make
it so that we can identify a texture 2d
by its renderer ID that way we can kind
of compare and that might be better than
using render IDs just because I don't
like the idea of having to bind a raw
renderer ID I think that's not great so
what we'll actually do here is change
this I wasn't gonna do this but now that
I'm actually providing out this code and
it's not in my head it's kind of
changing it's making more sense to do it
this way so what we'll do is for here I
will just set this equal to texture
right and then we need to go into
texture 2d or just texture
and what we need to do now is actually
write an operator that's going to be
able to compare the two textures so the
way that we'll do that is we'll write
the virtual operator equals equals and
this is a boolean operator obviously
Const texture 2d other Const
and to be honest I think this is
something that we can just chuck in over
here and set it equal to zero here so
we'll grab this and then we'll go to our
OpenGL texture and then we will override
this so override and then what this is
going to do is just basically return if
am render ID and and obviously like in
this case they should be the same type
maybe I will actually just drop this
down a little bit to make it a bit
easier I'm still going to keep it in the
header file M render ID equals will cast
this to an OpenGL texture ID and we'll
say other dot and render ID okay so
which is essentially comparing this
based on the the render IDs so if we go
back to our renderer what we should now
be able to do is write another kind of
for loop here that basically goes
through all of the stuff that is inside
our texture slots so we'll go will
iterate through all of our slots and
we'll actually start this at 1 of course
because our our index 0 is of course the
white texture you guys should all know
this by now this is going to be dot size
of course and in fact we don't actually
have to iterate through all of them
because we're only going to be up to
here in the current roll poll so let's
change this to just go up to the texture
slot index that's in use right because
if we've only submitted three textures
why would we iterate through all 31 or
32 like or well 31 because we start at 1
no point in doing that
then let's write an if statement here
that basically so a starter don't
texture slots so I equals now we need to
now compare this through the texture
rights we need to write some code
this now I'm not actually this should
probably yeah this is now that this is
gonna actually just compare the shared
pointers which is not what I want to do
and I'm afraid that the code is gonna
look rather ugly if I go around that
system because what I'm gonna have to do
is call dot data or what is it ah doc
get right that's gonna get me that's
gonna get me the pointer and then I'm
gonna have to dereference the pointer
and that way it's going to use my
operators so this is a bit I don't
really like this to be honest I guess
it'll work though for now so maybe let's
just keep it but yeah this I don't know
it will have to come up with some better
syntax for that maybe we'll actually
have a function or like some kind of
even a function outside of the texture
class that does this comparison for us
that we can use to basically check if an
asset is equal to another asset that
will take into refs and we'll be a lot
better than this basically so don't yet
don't look at this code too much okay
cool so if if the textures are equal so
we're iterating through all the textures
that we've submitted so far in this draw
call and we're seeing hey have we
already submitted this texture and if we
have submitted texture already then it's
already in this texture slot collection
we just need to get the current actions
lot which is I and then set that equal
through our texture index so to actually
index equals floor I right and then
obviously we don't need to keep looking
through all this so we can just break
alright cool
done pretty easy so now we have a
texture index that was the purpose of
all of this kind of code here
we now have an actual texture index that
we can put into our vertex attributes so
that we can actually have our texture be
rendered so text index right that's
going to be a flirt and that's going to
be whatever texture index we have right
in the current submission now if it's
zero it's white which means that it's
gonna sample from the white texture and
not actually draw anything well at least
not actually you know multiply
everything with one and we'll get our
actual vertex color untouched so if we
go back into what am I looking for the
attributes
we'll add in our flirt just flirt a text
index and we need to talk about the
shader now so if we go to actually
before we talk about the shader I want
to make sure that we render with all of
our with all of our textures so we need
to bind textures here right so to do
that we need to go through all of our
now one before we do that you can see
that we also bind this well we used to
bind this white texture I think we did
it somewhere here white texture bind
right so that's kind of important I
think that what we can do is probably
just set so we've set all of the okay so
we're setting everything to zero yet now
this doesn't need to be done any more I
want to point out because this is now an
object right that gets construed this is
now a smart pointer it's an object it
gets initialized it's not like an
primitive type that we need to
initialize so this is now gone but what
I do want to do is still set the texture
slot at index zero to our white texture
so asked out I've got white texture
right and then that way when we go
through everything we can bind
everything all right so now that we've
got that what we can do is inside here
we just need to go through we'll start
at index I
sorry we're starting at index zero
because we want to include the white
texture and we'll go all the way up to
let's say texture slot index so that's
whatever we ended up whatever the next
slot would have been so this is
essentially going to be all of our
actual textures that we've submitted and
just write underscore T here and then
what we're gonna do is bind them right
so texture slot i/o texture slots I
guess i dot bind and we need to bind
them at slot I right because the index
of that array is the texture slot and
that's yes that's all we have to do when
we flush so before we actually draw we
bind the create the correct textures and
that is it now let's kind of fill out
this text index everywhere so if we just
draw a color we can set that to zero
so text index equals zero right because
this is Australian color and zero is the
white texture so we'll bind that
everywhere and then if we scroll down we
need to do the same thing in our texture
function except obviously bind obviously
set text rate index to texture index and
in fact what I'm gonna do is rewrite
this card because I didn't like it so
we're gonna try cons float text index
equals zero and this will be our white
texture so this is just gonna make a
little bit more sense if someone reads
it and that's about it look at me good
good guy sure know just making sure the
code is as readable as possible it's
what everyone should be aiming to do
honestly all right cool and then we
obviously have like a transform I don't
know what we did with this I don't know
I don't even know if we still use a
transform but let's go back into that
let's go into our shader and check it
out so over here inside texture we need
true and I'm using a plug-in now to
about foot syntax highlighting and stuff
which is good but I'm obviously doesn't
know all my custom stuff in Florida a
text index right so we're adding a new
attribute here which is a texture index
we need to send that texture index out
of our varying thing we're getting to
the point where I probably convert this
into like a struct of just all of our
output data so that we're not kind of
just free-floating so many variables
like that text index we've still got a
view projection times position which ago
so yeah I transform just not being used
and then over here we'll accept that
text index so in floor text index and
now we need to actually sample from the
correct texture so if we look at this we
have a sample a 2d of textures we're
going to change that to be a sampler 2d
array right so now we have a bunch of
textures instead of just one way of 32
textures which is our maximum support a
number of textures
now again you'd probably want to like
custom make custom roller shader based
on that render capability and then we
can kind of dynamically just create a
new shared on the fly which will have
the number here additionally what I'm
about to do which is sample from a
non-constant sample from this float here
so I'll use that as a texture indexing
to hear that
may not be supported by all drivers it
works for me so just be aware that you
may need to in fact have a little bit of
a branch set up where you go through an
inch that ends up being you know you can
you switch them and so if that's not
supported you can use if statements to
actually basically sample from the
correct to actually index but hopefully
none of you run into that if you do let
me know in the comments below because
I'm interested if that's still a thing
in 2020 but basically what we want to do
is simply look at you textures ass will
convert this into an end and to convert
it to an end chip use this style class I
think in jail so you sorry V underscore
text index okay
so that's us sampling from the correct
texture and then the rest is gonna be
txt Ford times you tally factor times
color okay so that is what we end up
with and we'll obviously get rid of this
one now we should be good I think so if
we go back to render a 2d we should be
binding the right textures in the right
slice and doing everything hopefully
correctly I can't think of anything else
so I'm gonna have to just test this code
and see what happens and then I'll
probably realize that I've made it
horrible mistake but let's try with
outside without checkerboard texture cuz
that's the thing in the background um I
expect the transform the size that we've
said is that gonna work that might work
anyway let's just check this out so this
should be going I'm gonna put a
breakpoint here okay okay let's just run
it let's just run it and see what
happens but I was gonna put a breakpoint
here to make sure that we're actually
going to into the rad function okay so
we've got a bunch of stuff here
missing type-specific well that makes
sense
this needs to be a texture and if we go
to let's say we go to opengl texture we
can make this movie us I guess let's see
if this will compile yeah looks pretty
good to me
all right let's run this code see what
we get and we get nothing all right
as expected I guess let's take a look at
what went wrong so it's probably almost
definitely the whole texture binding
situation
if we go back to render a 2d let's take
a look so I expect that let's not draw
the texture for now so now we should
just be drawing this which may still
turn up to be not being rendered
correctly because we are of course
trying to multiply it with the white
texture so it seems like our white
texture isn't working either let's put a
breakpoint here and see what we are
dealing with let's get rid of all this
stuff come on I could just right click I
guess but anyway okay so draw quad okay
texture index of zero which is good and
everything else we have an actual color
yep so that's all being submitted
correctly and we have our index count I
guess so that should be good and if we
look at our flush or end scene and I
guess it would copy all of this stuff
now yeah I'm assuming everything else
would have just worked because we did
change that quad vertex structure
however everything obviously should have
been like you know correct here max
vertices we added this in here Tex index
it's a flirt not everything looks pretty
good to me and we have our white texture
which we created here and we set it up
and we bound it to slot zero
apparently so drink flush I guess let's
make sure that that's you know working
so there's texture slot zero find so
this should be able to a bunny flutter
around right he is one so I assume
that's our white texture oh okay I
forgot I can't believe I forgot that I'm
not having a good day we need to
obviously set the uniforms correctly so
this used to be right just us setting
you texture which was just one int but
now we're going to write another
function here called set int array right
and then this is going to basically take
in I guess we can just take in I'll just
say values and then we can have you and
32t count so this is what set in array
is going to look like we're going to go
back into shader and and that
here as well equals zero so now this set
int array function is going to be very
very similar here upload uniform int
array will have our values and our count
and then I will I guess I will just also
duplicate this function an array int
values and you instead of GT count we
will create that function and then will
get the uniform location of the name
obviously and then we'll just call
uniform one IV location counters count
and then values gonna be our values okay
that's it so now if we go back here what
we need to do is basically create our
samplers so we can say you and 32 T
samplers write 32 and then we'll iterate
through all of these equals 0 I is less
than 32 and I obviously should be using
s data max texture slots for this and
we'll just set sample as I equal to AI
okay so we're just ascending here with
all of our text as well so we get 0 1 2
3 4 5 etc all the way up to 31 in this
case and then we need to set int array
view textures samplers and then s data
max Texas loss okay so now we're
actually setting this properly now we
yeah this needs to be an inch not a
youant and that should be pretty good I
think let's hit f5 see what happens I
brought in 32 T here by the way but I
don't know if I should change it
elsewhere we'll see ok what do we get
well we still get nothing that's
somewhat surprising I'm having a really
bad day I guess I hope that's being set
correctly so we bind the texture shadow
which is our textures you'll sell you
textures we set you
that should all be correct I would
imagine yep so you can see let's get out
a hexadecimal display sample is 0
through two yep okay good
you underscore texture settings array so
let's see what that's actually doing I'm
assuming location it found a location
and then count 32 values should all be
here obviously let's just quickly see
we'll add it to watch comma 32 and yep
they're all here so you can see our
things here so what is going on with
let's look at our shader quickly it's
going to be a very long video
unfortunately where is our shader
where's our shader texture okay so is
that text index and everything correct
that's the other thing I should probably
check so yeah so we have an in float a
text index and then we output that to V
text index which is here and then we use
that to choose to get the right texture
and then uh what's our tiling factor we
probably don't set that that may be
what's going on let's let's remove the
tiny factor quickly and see if that's
the problem
no it's not okay let's just keep
removing stuff and see what what the
deal is so let's let's bring back color
let's make sure our CPU satisfy nice oh
it's not okay everything is a disaster
turns out so let's go back to basics
this is actually good this is gonna this
is gonna I'm gonna name this video like
texture stuff plus debugging uh
sometimes it's gonna be like an hour
long which is like a bit ridiculous but
anyway what have we done I don't even
understand okay so this stuff's fine
we're flushing everything we're drawing
I imagine yeah we're still doing like
all this stuff I don't have been going
through this path anymore by the way
we're just doing this stuff so what has
happened what has happened
we're still doing this yeah we still
didn't begin CNN saying all that stuff
is still there what have I done so I'm
probably looking at this being like dude
you've completely ruined everything
that's super weird okay so it has been
more time than I care to admit I mean
realistically it's been about three
minutes but I found the problem look at
this line it's it's here what what is
the problem I'll give you guys like five
seconds to see if you can see it it's
this it's you underscore color that's a
uniform color we do not use uniform
colors we use vertex colors which is
this varying here so this should have
been V color and if I launch it with V
color well then guess what we have
everything so let's it's such a small
thing but it sucks that it completely
ruins everything okay everything seems
to work now let's try and bring back our
checkerboard background here and see if
we can actually render that as well and
okay so that's kind of a little bit
black and weird and the scaling kind of
looks wrong so we'll need to investigate
that in a minute but everything seems to
render correctly
apart from that which is good so let's
remove you color because that doesn't
need to be a thing you tiling factor I
don't know like we if we want Italian
factor it has to be inside a vertex
attribute now if we want to have it into
inside a drawer call so I'm going to
like you know I might leave a little to
do tiling factor here but like it's
clearly not by me uniform we will remove
it so we have u textures here and that's
good okay cool so with that in mind is
now and I'll just clean up everything
else we just have your projection yeah
this is why it's important to keep your
shader is nice and clean by the way so
checkerboard texture should be bound
doesn't matter what that is that's how I
tie our tiling factor which I think we
don't use anymore we used to use it as a
uniform here but basically I think
everything else should work so we try it
so let's see what happens when we try
and render this right so what we do is
we've submitted
obviously it's the checkerboard
background so we can't find it in here
which is correct so this comes over here
and then we obviously add it we add this
texture to texture slot one right so
this is now in texture slot one so if we
look at this we now have our white
texture now one by one white texture and
I'll check out both texture okay it
looks pretty good we said texture index
to one everywhere which also is pretty
good and then when it's time to render
and we go over here we have hang on a
minute why is this one oh we forgot to
increment it okay that should have been
two because as soon as we've added a new
texture here it's important that we
increment the texture slot index because
that means that the next session is
gonna be in slot 2 so let's launch that
again and hopefully that was the final
issue and yes it was okay
now Italian factor obviously does not
work at the moment and also I believe
that size is no size is taken into
consideration here so what this size is
10 by 10 yeah I guess that's fine so if
we really want that to be centered we
would have had to it because 0 is the
center sorry
bottom left corner is where it starts
drawing from so because of that
obviously it will start drawing from
here and then we go all the way there so
we need to translate it if we want it if
we want it to be there in fact let's
just do that so we'll say this true - 5
- 5 and then we have a 10 by 10 so in
other words it's now it should now be
centered around the origin here you can
see it is ok tallying factor doesn't
work maybe something that will add in in
the future um in fact you know what
since this video is already like
embarrassingly long let's just - go
ahead and add it now what I'll do is
I'll have a text chord and then I'll
just have a florist called tiling factor
honestly because I don't think we're
gonna want to know a uniform tiling
factor so what we'll do is we'll add
another flirt here which is going to be
our tiling factor and then if we scroll
down over here we're just going to set
tiling factor 2 this is the texture 1 so
we'll set it to tiling factor and then
for the other 4 not for not drawing
textures we'll have to just set it to
well it doesn't really matter what it
gets set to we can set it to 0 for
example so Const it doesn't matter what
assets you because we shouldn't be
sampling anyway
oh no we will be sampling actually from
the white texture so we'll say tiling
fact I'll just set it to 1 and then we
just simply take this and put it
everywhere then in our shader we look at
location for tiling factor our floor
tiling factor then we pop this into here
and then we have this here sorry for the
amazingly descriptive language here that
I'm using and then we just multiply the
texture coordinates by Italian factor
and I think that should work so we are
setting Italian factor of 10 here and
everything else should be using Italian
factor of 1 I guess so looking at this
we now have our checkerboard texture
back which is nice let's set this to 1
for fun just to make sure that it
actually works which I expect it will
and there we have it okay cool so we can
now support textures now this is what
I'm interested in what happens if I
submit another chord with the same
texture let's make this tiling factor
even higher so like 20 or something and
let's make this a lot smaller so one by
one and we'll put it out like we'll
still have it in the origin so 0.5 and
0.5
negative 25 rather okay so now if we
launch this first of all we should see
the same texture being used but more
importantly what I'm interested in and
there it is with the really tiny tiling
texture and it looks like it's something
is kind of in the way that's super weird
it's supposed to be are supposed to be
like this ok that's super weird that I
don't even ok where negative let's put
it as zero maybe
I think it's just some weird Zed like
depth buffering issues going on here
let's bring it a little bit forward okay
that's good now so it's being obscured
by that but whatever let's now go into
here and make sure that as we submit
this it's actually finding our texture
so the first time it doesn't find it
right doesn't submit it second time is
our second one it should hopefully find
it and you can see it does right so this
is equal now and I'm assuming it's
actually if I go back here let's see if
I can go into step into specific and
then we can start to get like yeah yeah
that's gonna be super annoying I can
just go to GL texture and we can maybe
just put a breakpoint here and yes okay
so it is in fact hitting our function
it's comparing the to render IDs and
that's a lot good it really wanted to
make sure that they actually worked
correctly all right cool so that's it I
guess we have textures rendering now
using this batch renderer everything you
see here is in one drop hole which is
pretty cool cool all right what an
episode I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please hit that like
button please help support the series
and my channel on patreon Oklahoma for
such that shown on a huge thank you to
everyone who does in fact support this
channel I also wanted to say that I have
been doing live streams for patrons as
well so once a week I've just been
developing hazel dev which is like the
3d version of hazel that's been a lot of
fun so join up there show your support
and get access to these super amazing
live streams which you can then watch
after the fact that they've been
streamed which is also cool I think next
time we're going to continue on with the
batch render or Winnie we still need to
add like transformations and all of that
stuff and I really want to stress test
it as well but I hope you guys enjoy
this video and I will see you next time
good bye
[Music]